[Music]
now to our uplift at eight where we
share stories to brighten your day
today's story is about a three-year-old
boy named JH who loves construction he'd
been watching a construction project in
his neighborhood for weeks and one day
the crew did something special check it
out
yeah
[Laughter]
so that is his mom cheering as JH and
his Nanny watch his little toy truck
getting filled with dirt outside of
their North Carolina home
there's one guy who grabs a shovel and
he was going to fill it up and I think
the excavator operator was like oh no no
I got this and he started turning it and
they loved it they were smiling and
laughing and they thought it was so cute
that is adorable the construction team
even took a special photo with him
wearing his little helmet JH told his
mom he's a real construction worker now
that is so cute it's so cute teddy has
the very same little truck and by the
way mom knowing the proper term
excavator you've got a little book I
guarantee it with all the different
items labeled they checked through it
every night awesome love it I love it
it's so cool